snap is back
throwing it deep down the left side into
the end zone for gallop the ball is
broken up and complete unfortunately we
can get the job done and we all have to
own it i have to own it the coaching
staff has to own it do you have a
timetable when you're gonna make a
decision no how much do you want to be
the coach here
in 2020. i want to be the coach of the
dallas cowboys
but we'll see what happens
oh jason garrett the cowboys head coach
remains in limbo and we don't know when
the cowboys are going to let us know
whether or not garrett will continue
it's a tuesday edition of pro football
talk live the last pft live
of whatever decade of the year of the
decade not just the year but the decade
if we believe that the decade begins
2020. you know there are some folks out
there how could that even be
i know but i hear from them all the time
and now that you brought it up i'm going
to hear from them again the decade
doesn't end until the end of 2020 uh but
either way so when we celebrate that can
we agree it's the end of the year well
yeah but no i i want to get into the
better topic here what how could that be
so it wasn't the end of the 20th century
when we celebrated you know the year
2000 that was not it it really was 2001.
where were you through all were you in
some sort of a haze because i don't pay
attention to stupid so when stupid
happens i decided let me check it out
yeah the the new millennium actually
began according to many january 1 of
2001 not jerry january 1 of 2000 that's
that's a 20 year old fact so that's just
some stupid like internet rumor i mean
what is it no the the fact is that there
are people who will insist
that january 1 2000 is meaningless as it
relates to the changing of a millennium
that it was the year after that that's
so the point is i understand why there
are people out there a subset of the
millennium truthers who are now decade
truthers who are saying that the new
decade doesn't begin until a year from
now and look i don't
either out of the show i was born in
i
care
1980 so was i not born in the 80s or
does that really count as the 70s i just
i don't know now i'm not confused
okay are you done no i'm just that
that's the dumbest crap ever it's the
new decade coming up tomorrow and
tomorrow is the new decade sorry it's
fine i'm not fighting you on i'm just
pointing out no i know but once you say
it you've guaranteed that i'm going to
get 15 emails in the next 15 seconds
from people who are saying the new
decade doesn't begin until next year so
thank you for that you're welcome
we have far more important things to
discuss because we have coaching
vacancies and we actually have one
coaching vacancy that isn't a vacancy
yet because the cowboys are going to
milk this thing for all it's worth and
chris there are some who believe that
this is just an effort
by jerry jones the consummate salesman
to take over as many news cycles as he
can why fire a coach on monday when you
can string it out and everybody's
talking about the cowboys you know when
they name a pope there's just one puff
of white smoke well maybe they can come
up with multiple puffs of smoke and we
can be paying attention to the cowboys
and only the cowboys throughout this job
search from the moment they have a
vacancy to the moment they start doing
interviews to the moment they finally
fill the vacancy they can corner the
market on buzz on chatter on attention
so i don't know how much of that is part
of this
there's no reason at this point to think
that they aren't going to fire jason
garrett but they definitely are taking
their time and they're going to meet
with him reportedly again today they met
with him yesterday some think that
basically what they're trying to do is
just simply give him time to make the
proper exit talk to everybody needs to
talk to you know he's been there a long
time he's been right organization for
well over a decade yeah but anyway the
bottom line is
jason garrett still not fired black
monday has come and gone
and uh we're just waiting for the
cowboys to let us know what they're
gonna do and think about this steven and
jerry jones they love to talk they
canceled their appearances for early
this week on 105.3 the fan in dallas
that tells you that this is a different
time for the cowboys where they are
choosing to be discreet and silent as
this thing works its way through but i
think tomorrow wednesday is the day to
watch for some sort of a decision and
the decision is still expected to be
jason garrett out as cowboys coach after
a decade a decade a true decade a
10-year stint in the job whenever that
decade began right it was a decade uh
well all right first off i don't believe
the the the jones family is very smart
we know that we understand they under uh
know how to monetize i don't believe for
a second that like come on they're doing
this just for the extra news cycle i i
don't know i mean oh i wouldn't put that
past
well that's part of being smart but why
not doing the interviews then then do
the interviews and make some real news i
you know why why would you cancel out of
interviews then if you don't want if you
want to be the head of the news cycle
man we'd all be tuned in to jerry jones
and what he's got to say about the
cowboys or stephen jones so i just
challenged that i might be wrong you're
right they are smart i get that all that
uh i also think they look at it and you
know they go hey this guy's been here
for a decade he's you know been here for
longer than a decade you know there's
more than just jason garrett jason's
garrett's father worked for jerry jones
and the dallas cowboys at one point and
also it is a big decision and the jones
just don't take it lightly and i just
don't think they're just gonna sit there
and you know
just oh you're fired you know right
after the game i just don't think
they're that type of people i do think
there's a sense of loyalty here to jason
garrett they understand the type of man
human being he is how hard he's worked
he's invested his life in that he does
it for good reasons he tries to
improve people let alone be a really
good football coach and uh i think
inevitably this all happens mike right i
mean it's just yeah i think they're
probably giving jason the respect to go
around do things he's got to do within
the organization and not make it look so
what do i want to say you know just so
severe like oh we're chopping your head
off right now the game's over uh at
least that's my take on it
they're giving him the respect or at
least what they think is the respect
that he deserves for all of the time
he's been with the team as a player as
an assistant as a guy that they were
trying to groom into the next tom landry
and they tried and they tried and they
tried and they're finally admitting that
it didn't work but they're treating him
differently than other teams treat their
coaches they they believe
if we're psychoanalyzing what they're
really up to here they believe he's
earned that so he gets a more elaborate
exit than another coach would who gets
you know uh gets tapped on the shoulder
on sunday night and told uh you're out
like the browns did with freddie kitchen
so i i can understand that i can
understand that if they're if they're
doing that but the clock is ticking yes
and other teams are lining up interviews
and you don't want this well to linger
because the senior ball is going to be
here before you know you like to have a
coach in place when it's time to go
scout the players at the senior bowl
well you no no doubt about it but yeah
yeah we know the most important scouts
are the jones family themselves but you
know like to me the other thing that
speaks to this and i'm glad you brought
it up the fact that they're kind of you
know taking their time with this and oh
yeah you know everybody's getting the
jump on them with interviews and getting
their you know head coaching candidates
list all together and all that
i i don't i just feel like the cowboys
know something we don't know i i just
feel that way that's why they're in
nowhere they know who they're going to
hire but they already know they're going
to like they you know and again this is
total just i'm just throwing out bull
crap right here but i'm just throwing an
example like they maybe know mike
zimmer's coming to the end in minnesota
like you've said or something like that
i haven't said that oh god now you're
gonna get me i didn't mean like you said
the rumors are out there there is plenty
of rumors there i mean i read it all
over the internet yesterday so there is
that thought that that's there to be had
i mean i saw too many even tv shows
talking about could this be mike
zimmer's last game as the minnesota
vikings head coach but i'm just saying
as an example i don't know any of that
mike zimmer please don't get pissed at
me i didn't mean it that way i'm just
trying to give an example that i feel
like the cowboys ownership the jones
family
might really know what they're going to
do with their next move and that's why
they're not in a big panic to get
everything started here
yeah i think that has something to do
with it and i think that when somebody
just emailed me is it a firing if the
contract actually expires yes it is it
is a firing if the contract expires
that's interesting
if the coach wants to stay
and the team doesn't want him the mere
fact that the contract expired doesn't
make it any it's look you still have to
end the relationship right under the
laws of most states when your contract
expires you become an at will employee
you're still employed there until you
resign so yes it's still a firing if the
cowboys say to jason garrett please
kindly remove your things from the
premises but the bottom line is i agree
with you that they they know what
they're going to do next most of these
owners go into these processes knowing
what they're going to do next that's one
of the reasons why the rooney rule in
spirit doesn't necessarily work because
you're not going to compel a guy who
knows who he wants to hire to not come
to a decision as to who he wants to hire
without regard to requirements that
certain types of interviews be done and
i'm a believer in the rooney rule and i
think it needs to be tweaked i think it
needs to be modified i think it needs to
take into account
that that these owners do decide
that they're going to hire this person
without regard to what they're required
to do and there is benefit in still
getting names of minority coaches into
the mix so we'll talk about them and
they get interviews elsewhere and it
promotes the
so
maybe at some point
the guy who you decide on ahead of time
falls into the category of a guy that
maybe would have been overlooked because
he didn't get those interviews in the
past so i'm still a supporter of it but
jerry jones is going to do what he's
going to do he's going to decide on who
he wants to decide on and i think he
already knows even if it's not who it's
going to be
number one number two number three right
on the wish list is and he'd probably
like to nail down number one uh before
he moves on but then you have to go out
and do a search that seems like it it is
fully compliant that's the other problem
here so look bottom line is the cowboys
i think know what they're gonna do they
know what they're doing this isn't some
accident this is all part of a broader
plan
and what they are ultimately going to do
will reveal itself to us in due course
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports